(audience applauding)
- So we have,
someone on the line who is
very familiar with that song.
Can we say hi to him, everybody?
What's up Ed Sheeran.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
Get it out. Get it out people.
They love you.
(audience applauding)
It is great to see you again.
I will... I'm gonna lead with this.
It is absolutely terrifying
to be singing someone's
song and them listening
while you're doing it.
(laughing)
I was like, "Oh my God!"
I was like, "It's Sheeran."
I love that song though.
Bad habits is such a jam.
I love it.
Why did you write that?
- Thank you.
I loved your version by the way.
I was listening to your version,
wondering whether I
should have actually used
more electric guitar in
it cause it sounded...
Sounded pretty great.
(laughing)
I wrote here...
One is by accident.
I was working with
the two people that I'd
made the album with,
Johnny and Fred.
And Fred is primarily
like a dance producer
and he played me a tune that
he was just about to release.
That was a really,
really heavy dance tune.
And I just said, you know what,
let's just try and make something upbeat
that could also be
played on acoustic guitar
and life basically.
And yeah, it just kind
of happened by accident.
I wasn't expecting it to be first single
and yeah it's one of these songs that
it sort of came out and
it's just kind of stuck
and it's not like...
It hasn't been like my
biggest charting single
but I think it'll end up being...
- Longevity.
- One of my biggest songs just over time.
- Yeah. That's longevity.
- Very, very gradually.
- And that's the best kind of song though.
And also I didn't wanna
freak you out but my idea was
actually to completely
do it with just a piano
and I wanted to make
it really dark and sad
and then I didn't wanna freak you out.
So I kept it like this one,
(laughing)
but I love a song like that.
I feel like you write songs like that.
That you can literally do with
a huge band electric guitars.
Do it big. You could do dance.
You could do singer, songwriter.
I think it's an amazing gift you have.
Songwriting. Everybody knows that.